in this video I'm gonna talk about the
best fashion accessories for men in 2018
I am Daniel Moritz and this is D LM
model lifestyle
all right now I'm not gonna waste your
time by talking too much and let's start
whoa that's a big way the best fashion
accessories of those that will never go
out of style
so let's start with the first one the
wallet my top pick for 2018 is Tommy
Hilfiger's Ranger leather wallet he's
crazy how low the price is compared to
the quality and look at this wallet I
will add a link in the description so
you can check it out it is not too big
and it is not too small either it is the
perfect size
it also has just the right amount of
space for your cards this wallet is a
perfect gift for any man there are a lot
of different colors that you can choose
from but stick with the black or brown
color so that it will fit in with most
of your outfits so we got the wallet the
second one is sunglasses my top pick for
sunglasses is Ray Bans aviator
sunglasses they never go out of style so
it is an investment that you can make
the shape fits in with most clothing
styles because they look sporty
and classy at the same time there are
many different colors that you can
choose from but I will link my favorite
in the video description below
third one is watch let's look at the
best watch for 2019 my topic is the
brown leather watch from Hugo Boss this
is style it is always better to invest
in one or two good watches compared to
several low quality watches that look
but it is really terrible to wear a
great outfit in a bad watch now I also
like the black leather watch which will
fit in with my other outfits that does
not go well together with the brown
leather watch number four is bags let's
look at the best bag for 2018 the
messenger bag is back and it is here to
stay my favorite for 2018 is AOL's 1/2
club crossover bag this bag is a sign of
elegance and like the aviator sunglasses
it can never go out of style this
stylish messenger bag complement a great
looking at tire and it actually fits in
with most styles of clothing another
reason why this bag is number one is
because it is handmade from real 100%
leather and the price is affordable
number five is a scarf the best car for
2019 let's look at that my favourite
scarf is a long cashmere black scarf
fuller on every man needs a good quality
galactus scarf this high-quality scarf
from Mulan is soft and just the right
length to tie any scarf not buried with
a pea coat or casual jacket to look
great alright guys so now you know my
best fashion accessories for men in 2018
I have out of the links of all the
products in the description if you want
to check those out if you liked the
video give me a thumbs up subscribe and
I'll see you in the next video
you
[Music]